we'll always sense that drag does not
conceal it actually reveals who you
really are
so get ready my drag name like I said
sometimes they just come out of the blue
and I think those are the best you're
like oh my gosh thank you Jesus and my
dad is a car dealer back in Allentown
Pennsylvania and one day I had to go
thank who's from Allentown oh wait oh my
god amazing go fairs I had some
experience with the football team but
anyway I was back home I had to go to
like his office and there on the
showroom window was my drag name Lisa
new Sonata and I really liked it I think
it suits me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god we're together
[Applause]
[Music]
it's happening everybody we're even
gonna make the times up my lips are very
large and my beautiful mama
is it time to turn around
[Music]
[Applause]
I kind of look a little bit like
Michelle visage we're not here with
Carson Kressley we're here with I my
name is divinity Tyler I am the third
cousin once removed of Trinity Taylor
the tech so it's not Lissa Newson Anna
Lisa news Sanada is the amazing drag
queen but that is not her you know I
just wasn't feeling her today and after
Trinity worked her magic I just feel
like I'm divinity Taylor after that
panel
it was so eye-opening you two both
opened up I mean oh how what was it like
getting transformed into this character
in front of everybody while giving your
whole life story thank you um no this is
crazy I felt like I was purposely not
looking in the mirror at all and Trinity
was doing her magic and I was like only
wonder what its gonna look like and I
thought when she was saying like oh we
don't have enough time oh you don't look
that good and then I saw how gorgeous I
looked and I was like oh my god I'm in a
fish
is there another celebrity that you feel
like you look like now I feel like that
I look like Michelle visage Arielle the
mermaid and Trinity all had a baby and
that is me